hey there townscapers and welcome back
to my channel
if this is your first time here welcome
and thank you so much for coming today
please do me a favor and hit the like
button and share this video with other
people if you think they would enjoy it
it will help me out a lot and i would
really really appreciate it so today i
was on twitter
and i ran into an account named moko j
i hope i'm saying that right i'm not
really sure how to pronounce it um but
anyways they created this program called
townshill
and it's pretty cool it has keyboard
shortcuts and tools to manipulate and
edit your builds and
i just think that's very awesome um
because it could be really helpful when
you want to do really large builds but
i'll leave the links down in the
description below so you can download it
and just check it out for yourself so
we're going to go ahead and talk about
it
there are five tools level paint dig
replicate and merge so level adds extra
levels of course
paint allows you to change colors
replicate allows you to copy and paste
levels and
merge allows you to combine two separate
sets of blocks into one
and dig which is something that i've
actually been hoping for
in a future update it gives you the
ability to remove a certain set of
blocks within a determined amount of
levels
and when i say like hoping for not this
one tool
exactly but something like a paint brush
or something to come with a future
update where you can just click on a
certain section
and and just get rid of it and then you
can just you know start over on that
part
and you know not have to do the constant
clicking to delete everything
um but yeah it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool i'm really excited about it so
let's go ahead and start with level this
example shows you how i made multiple
levels using the tool
i did this with a simple three level
building i saved the code to the
clipboard and i chose to add two levels
of height you want to save to clipboard
and then load it into the game as you
can see it added two extra levels from
the bottom
so that's pretty cool and if you want
the blocks to be brick you do have to
check the plane box or it will not
generate the way you wanted to it'll
generate stilts instead so you'll have
like that empty space
um you can also add extra levels in
different colors so that's nice too
so next we'll do replicate i started
with a three level building
first level was cobblestone second level
is stilts in the third level is brick of
course
you want to add it to the clipboard and
then you add your height and number of
copies so i'll add four levels of height
and three copies so copy it to the
clipboard and load it into the game
and let's see it copied the first three
levels and so now
i have 12 extra levels so that's like 15
levels right there so that's pretty cool
i like that it gives you an extra leg up
on building really tall structures
um so that's pretty cool so next you're
going to do
merge it's pretty simple and all you
have to do is take the clipboard code
of two separate builds and paste them
together into these text fields right
here
and make sure to do the save button
click the save button it won't work so
after you save your clipboard codes into
the application
click the save to clipboard button and
load it into the game and
now you have merge two files into one so
i'm gonna be playing with this a little
bit
and like merging like really really
large files just to see what happens so
i think that's gonna be pretty cool
it might break my computer but we'll see
we'll see what happens so next is the
paint feature
and i really love this feature because
you can change the colors without having
to constantly click and replace
and so that's pretty awesome so with
this feature you really have to keep in
mind how tall or how many levels your
build is
and then you need to figure out if you
want to recolor the whole thing or if
you just want to do like a certain set
of levels so for this example i'm going
to use what i believe is a 24 level tall
build also remember that levels are
counted from the bottom of the grid so
even though this build is floating in
the sky and it only looks to be about 12
to 14 layers tall
it's really about 24 layers because it's
counting the space below
so what i'm gonna do is change one of
the colors from
levels 20 to 24. i chose these layers
by using the height filter right here
and then i change the color
your desired color should be chosen in
the colors option
and your old color should be chosen in
the filters option so
save the clipboard and then load it in
the game
and now all my tan bricks are green so i
thought it's pretty cool
it's really awesome um because it really
takes a lot of effort out of trying to
change colors if you have a lot of
colors that you want to change or if you
want to go to an old building you just
want to see what happens
so um of course i was saving the best
teacher for last
and that is dig so as stated earlier dig
allows you to remove a certain set of
blocks within a determined amount of
levels you can now manipulate your bills
by removing blocks just to get a
different look or you can get rid of a
chunk of blocks if you want to do
something completely different
um this will also help you out if you
don't want to start a new file for a
fresh grid
so that's pretty cool and the way this
tool works is that you can do it in
percentages so on the right there's an
example
of what some percentages do we'll remove
10 15 and 100
of level 16 through 24 and then we'll go
ahead and remove 100
of all the blue box so first i want to
change the percentage to 10
and then choose my layers i will pick 20
to 24.
let's save this to the clipboard and
load it into the game
so now you can see that it's removed 10
of the blocks within levels 20 to
24. so let's go ahead and change it to
50
and here's what it looks like when it's
at 50 removed
uh let's go ahead and see what looks
like with 100 and so now all levels
of 20 and 24 are gone let's go ahead and
remove the levels above those stairs
that looks like about two or
four of them so now we have removed all
of level 16 through 24.
let's go ahead and take it a step
further and remove 100 of the blue brick
you want to choose 100
and then go and pick your desired color
under filter
and change the height filters to the
right levels for me those levels would
be 12 through 16.
so make sure you copy the original to
the clipboard
and then copy the settings from town
shell to your clipboard
and then upload that to the game now i'm
only left with
10 bricks on level 16 through 24 and any
other blue bricks that are left are
below those levels
i just think that's awesome that's like
my favorite setting in this program
honestly that and paint
but that's pretty much it for this video
i think it's pretty cool how you can
manipulate the levels and even the
colors outside of paint with the filters
in each setting
even though i will say i need more
practice with recoloring and level and
replicate because it could be kind of
confusing especially if you don't click
the play
option because your color won't show up
and it'll just be stilts but
anyways um show the creator some love
and download this on github if you like
it their twitter is also down in the
description
thank you so much for stopping by i
really really appreciate it i can't
stress that
enough if you enjoyed this video please
do me a favor hit the subscribe button
as this will help me out a lot
again thank you so much please stay safe
out there and i will see you next time